before we get into the match it's it's a  very very special day of course a man  who's dominated the Chess World for  close to 15 years I would say pretty  much single-handedly won the last five  World Championships  it's Law Office in his birthday what we  like to say to Magnus  well obviously I'm paying tribute  um with uh the Jersey both to um that's  Fresh's favorite uh football club of  course and uh also the country  um  Qatar who's uh host hosting the probably  the least corrupt  um world cup of all time so I'm paying  tribute to both of them and um  obviously this will they will from now  on be be uh the world baguette day which  I'm also very um  very happy about